hello there steve kaufman here
come on
i'm not going to say hello and how are
you in all these different languages
but um
i intend to have a little rant this
evening
which i enjoy doing
i just had dinner and my wife is playing
the piano so you may hear her
uh piano in the background which is nice
uh i'm going to rant within the time
limit of of
youtube which is uh 10 minutes
we in canada we have a a
an official government agency called the
office of the
uh
language commissioner
commissar let's call him the commissar
the commissar of languages
the commissar of languages
is on record in the newspapers
as saying
that um
let me see if i can find it here
something drastic has to be done
and what does he say here drastic action
needed to solve language issues before
olympics
like drastic like wow
and what he says is the harper
government that's our prime minister
harper must show leadership and
intervene with drastic action to ensure
that francophone athletes and visitors
at the 2010 vancouver games will get
service in their language
federal official languages commissioner
graham fraser said
tuesday what a complete idiot
vancouver and whistler are english
speaking
areas
if the olympic games were held in
quebec city which is predominantly
french speaking then most of the
services
and most of the proceedings the
restaurants and everything else will be
in french
of course you have to provide services
in the languages of the visitors and in
the case of canada you have to provide
an even higher level of service for the
other official language
but
if quebec wants to feature french
because that's their culture
fine if i'm in the italian part of
switzerland i expect italian to be
featured
we don't need a commissar dictating
what language is to be you be used where
this is a typical example of
somebody who has a budget trying to make
himself
important
um
you know there are so many languages in
the world yeah canada's english and
french fine if i'm in french canada i
speak french if i'm in english canada
speak english
at the airport there are signs in both
languages
now mr fraser our commissar of languages
decided that vancouver has a very low
score in terms of providing french
language services but we also have
signage in chinese and korean and
japanese and spanish because these are
the people who come through our airport
so that's a normal thing to do these are
the people who need to
um be provided with instructions and and
and information in their language
you know there are so many languages in
this world
the fact that english and french
certainly english
is dominant in the world is a absolute
accident of history
the fact that portuguese is spoken by
200 million people is an accident of
history
try and find britain on a map of the
world it's a little
foggy island
portugal is even smaller it's just so
happened that a particular point in
history
people from portugal were able to impose
their language on
an enormous area called brazil
and people from britain or from england
were able to impose their language on
other places but at different parts of
different times in history i mean you
know for example the silk road the
common language
uh on the silk road was a form of
persian called sagdian
that could have been a world language
but with the
changes that took place
the the you know the the mongol
invasions
and so forth sagdian never achieved that
but perhaps persian or sagdian or
various forms of persian should be a
world language i mean the mongols they
dominated everything from from russia to
now that's my granddaughter and i'm
gonna take that and ask her if she'll
allow me to call her back
no it's not my granddaughter so my wife
will take that call
um
the point is this you know
let's not get carried away with the
sanctity of different languages
languages are for communication people
who come to the olympic games at
whistler
will manage
they'll some of them will speak
different languages there will be guys
interpreters if every single sign in
every single store is not in english and
french
equally uh you know displayed it's
really not an issue for anybody who's
halfway sensible
it only matters to rabid
language nationalists in quebec
and for government bureaucracies like
the one run by mr fraser a completely
useless idea
fraser is the same guy who said that
anyone graduating from a university in
canada should be bilingual
well
i'm sorry the nearest
french-speaking community of any
significance to vancouver is 5 000 miles
say 8 000 kilometers away
there's no way that that's gonna happen
uh why should you say that people who
are outstanding scientists or
outstanding in whatever field
in order for them to graduate from
university they have to speak french
because
uh just under a quarter of the
population in canada uh is
french-speaking and there are certain
people bureaucrats and others who have
made a career
out of being bilingual as if that makes
them closer to to sainthood uh mr fraser
how many languages do you speak so you
speak french and you go around prance
around the country speaking french and
you think you're some kind of phenomenal
uh person
uh no french is a nice language i love
french i love french and i'm a canadian
nationalist i believe in canada and i
think that having two languages in
canada is a great thing but i have to be
fair
most people don't have an opportunity to
use french and they don't speak it so
stop trying to force this kind of stuff
on everybody and i don't demand it of of
people in quebec who are happily french
canada if french speaking and may or may
not speak english anyway
that
is mr fraser
what i'm saying is let's be reasonable
we have these language nationalists i
read a tremendous book
a novel written by
ruiz i think it's carlos ruiz staphon
who happens to be catalan
and he wrote a book in spanish castilian
spanish which i read in spanish and it's
called la sombra del viento
i loved it now there are some
sophisticated people who say it's not so
whatever to me it was a phenomenal book
i loved the way he used the language
spanish
i loved the plot the mystery inside a
mystery inside a mystery i couldn't put
it down from beginning to end i loved
every moment of it la sombra del viento
the shadow of the wind get it
but apparently
in catalonia in barcelona barcelona
the catalan nationalists are all upset
at rita von who is
and they say he should have written his
book in catalan
what for who's going to read it in
catalan gets serious
he writes because he wants people to
read his book to recognize his book
there's 300 million people
who can read it in spanish there's six
million people who can read it and cut
the line
and people are going to notice it in
spanish and they're going to translate
it into other languages why would he
possibly write it in catalan
so i think language should be about fun
and enjoyment and you know any of the
dominant world languages can today
they're there by luck i mean russian i
love russia russia i love what i'm doing
in russia russia and of course i always
get a kick out of the rushes because
they get all hung up about trying to say
you know stalin was a great guy we were
so powerful blah blah
that was a
black chapter in russia's history
the way in which the the muscovy
expanded
within literally a hundred years of the
pacific ocean is a tremendous
achievement the energy of the russian
people to do that those that were
involved but russia was lucky it could
have been another language it could have
been lithuanian maybe cree you know
under different circumstances maybe some
of the native
uh american languages might have
achieved some kind of dominate
domination maybe it would have been
i don't know swahili i mean it's all
luck and chance all languages are
equally valuable and language learning
and language speaking should not be a
political act it should be something
that we do
because we enjoy them and because we
appreciate them
as examples of of human creativity and
there you have my 10 minute rant and now
i got to go do the dishes bye